so it's works okay
so welcome everyone I'm Alana Devon
Thomas and I work as a security
researcher at the NASA cure where we use
frida for an automat emitted analysis of
mobile apps but the reason I'm here to
talk about three days well where did
this all came from it was as a developer
I've done a lot of well I tried to
develop interoperable software for Linux
train drop with closed source
proprietary protocols how closed
proprietary protocols and then I had to
do some reverse engineering and as I did
this I found myself needing tools for
this but before we go into that I'm just
going to show you what we're going to do
today so we'll have the debugger on the
right which is the target process that
we want to analyze and on the left
that's us where the debugger and using
frida it's going to allocate a
bootstrapper create a bootstrapper some
code inside that other process that's
hidden behind the scenes so I don't need
to think about it but I'm just going to
show you like visually what's happening
and then we create a thread frida
creates a thread in that other process
and that executes the boots wrapper
which then loads a like a shared library
which is our agent and then it
establishes the communication channel
back to us and across this community
communications channel we can tell it to
do things like so we have a a JavaScript
interpreter inside here so we can expose
a set of API and make it do things and I
want to spoil too much some work and
talk about what things but basically the
motivation behind this is that when
you're doing reverse engineering at
least my experience you create tools
because every target is different so you
can't just create one tool to to
reverse-engineer any software because
software it's different every time they
have some commonalities but usually you
want to create a tool because you know
you figure out what kind of API
using internally and then you want to
spy on those api's and that's where
Freda comes in so it's also an important
thing to be able to do this across
platforms without having to create a to
relearn everything or to write something
perfect every time
and as your reverse engineering you temp
to discover something and then you adapt
your tooling and then discover something
else and then you keep adapting so yeah
it's like a short feedback loop so if
you have to continuously adapt it's
important that that loop is short so you
don't run out of patience and I'll
actually I'm back in the day I created a
Windows tool for this kind of reverse
engineering was kind of like Wireshark
but at the API level so it could show
you the socket communications but also
the encrypted stuff so it would inject
codes into the target process and set
between the application and the crypto
libraries and intercept those calls and
show to you decrypted depends on the
antivirus because yeah I Pro uses some
things that might some techniques that
might set off antivirus but right yep
but it has you have there's several ways
you can use Frieda you can also load it
with LD preload or similar mechanism we
can if you have the source code of the
application you can also modify the
application to load the library that you
are the agent well it's called a gadget
in case but so yeah that's what Frieda
is technically dynamic invitations will
kit just means it's a scriptable
debugger kind of but unlike a debugger
the code is running inside the target
process so you're not sitting on the
outside you're sitting on the insights
or in the context of the process you can
do anything that process can do which
simplifies a lot of things and it's
scriptable but you don't have to you can
also use this for c c++ because it's
highly modular and
the high-level API that we're going to
use today it's just a composition of the
different components that you can use in
isolation and it's open source and it
works on the major platforms and that's
continuously expanded expanding so qnx
was not done by me for example and so
the mips support was not either so
basically a you would use for reverse
engineering for Grandma would be working
and so on but the key here is that it
should be should allow you for rapid
development of new tools the short
feedback loop so I think we've talked
enough we should show actually show it
so to do that we're just gonna create a
really tiny dummy hello world
application and yeah so what we're going
to do is that we're going to have this
program offices readable oops
it's going to to have a variable n it's
gonna name that loop that calls a
function f with an incrementing and it's
going to delay by one second between
each call and then we're going to create
this function and it's going to just
print off the number that you gave it in
and and we're also going to tell you
that F is at this memory address we
assumed that is not in line for this
example so we're really in tight control
here we just want to - easily to see
what's going on without starting with a
really complex application so that's why
we're writing this now
[Music]
University for sleep okay okay so we
have this program it's running and it's
calling that function every second with
an increment incrementing integer as the
argument okay so now let's use frida so
we will use the frida Python bindings
there's bindings for several languages
but for here we're just going to demo it
with the bindings that the Python
bindings they look the same
pretty much just adapted to local
conventions like camel case in Java or
snake case in Python so yeah okay so
session frita attach can you get a pit
or a process name yeah we'll use a
process name hello so then we get a
session and across on this session we
can create a script
session create script and here we give
it some JavaScript to run okay and then
we're going to load the script and then
we should just block so we don't
terminate if we do we it will undo
everything so okay yeah we always delete
load the script as well yes sorry I'm
here we load from a file okay and then
we're going to create this agent that
we're going to run inside this other
process and we know that this function
is at this address a SLR may might make
it end up in a different address so
that's why we're printing it out we can
also use the bug symbols or it was
exported we look it up that way so but
here
we're just going to use the address so
interceptor is an API in Frieda that you
where you can allowing you to intercept
function calls so give it the address of
the function that we want to intercept
calls to and then we define a handler
for an enter when it's called give us a
call define one for on leave when it's
returning but we won't need that and
here we have access to the argument list
while assuming that it has a default
call Convention and and there's some
assumptions there but you can also
access to registers but I'm jumping
ahead of myself so we can do console.log
here F called with M equals arcs 0 2 in
32 okay so we have written an agent that
attaches the probe so to speak to this
function so whenever it's called this
line of code here gets executed
synchronously and it's just gonna log
the first argument and all right that
depends on the platforms on Linux
currently we hijack a running thread and
make it called pthread create to create
our own thread and that calls dl open
but on on mac OS on iOS and I have
written a dynamic linker where we can do
it from the outside of the process and
just map our library into the process
without it having file system access so
in case of sandbox processes on Windows
yeah exactly
but for Windows there's yeah we want to
have more mechanisms so ok so so we have
written a parking program here that just
attaches to this process loads this
agent and runs it in there hopefully it
will work
let's try it okay so we'll just do
Python explore the pie and if you pay
attention on the right hopefully yeah so
you can see that our probe is getting
hit and it's logging the argument so we
see you see that they're in sync it's
getting it's happening in real-time so
yeah now we know what n is the argument
to this function but actually we did
write some boilerplate code here and
that was just to show you how you can
use to read s bindings you don't have to
do the right that's kind of boilerplate
wherever a use case but this is just to
show you how you would do it so so you
could use Frida's rebel so you do frida
a name of the process and ll - L for
load and the agent and there we go
that's much simpler I should have set up
okay so we have that and I just want to
show you one thing we can actually
change this and save if you pay
attention now so it reloads the file so
text monitors this the repple will
monitor this file and whenever it
changes it will reload the script so
that means you have a short feedback
loop you can adapt your instrumentation
and instantly see the results if this
code readable by the way okay so the
next thing you might want to do is
modify our an argument coming into the
function so what you could do here is
that you can do args 0 equals and take
existing value and add
in thousand to it if I save this
actually we can you'll see here that
yeah the function is seeing a different
argument now and and this happens at the
edge of the batter of the function so we
don't actually change em in the parents
go just to be clear yeah so we don't
change n here because now if I if I stop
the ripple and you pay attention on the
right it's back to normal so that the
instrumentation is reverted so this goes
away the the agent running inside will
detect it and will revert everything
okay so we know this program pretty well
so how about speeding up time for
example so we know that it's calling
sleep and that's what is using to drive
its clock so to speak so what we could
do let's just load the agent again is
that we could I'll just remove this code
we could do intercept or replace to
entirely replace the implementation so
again and now we need the implementation
existing implementation to replace so
we'll do module find export by name and
we know is using sleep so we'll look
that up and then ask the replacement
will create a native callback so we give
it a function
it's given a duration to sleep that's
the first argument I will do something
here and then the return type is void
that's probably in two actually oh yeah
that's its a UN and the UN okay
let's accept some event and then here we
could use Frida's thread sleep to just
sleep for say 50 milliseconds so if I
save this and you pay attention on the
right it's it speeds up now I patched
the implementation the beginning of the
implementation with the jump
so yeah in line hooking busy yeah and we
can revert it again and it's back to
normal
another thing you might want to do is to
call that function yourself that could
be useful for fasting for example of
finding bugs but also to if there's a
custom and decryption function
internally you could call it to decrypt
something so do new native function we
need the address of this function that
we want to call and that's here and we
know it returns the return type is void
and the argument type is int 1 in and
here did create a loop okay so if we run
this agent you should if you pay
attention now here we called five times
if I reload the script again just by
saving it and we'll happily get so now
we have a way to to call functions
that's how you do that
and these scripts or these agents that
you create that run inside target
processes they can also communicate you
can also communicate with them so they
can send and receive messages so I'm
just going to show that quickly here so
you can do RPC exports equals and then
for example call well just F give it the
argument and and it just calls F with
the end you get okay and now if we go
back to our Python program after we load
the script we can do script exports
that's a magical object so whatever you
access on it it will be a function a
generator function so you can do agent
dot F on or for I in range 10 call it
with I and then block actually we don't
need to do that here
[Music]
okay so have this script it declares a
native function to call this function in
the process memory address space and
then we export a function f and then on
the Python side we just on the script we
do exports dot F to call the function so
if you try that and you pay attention on
the right it's called ten times so you
could that way you can expose API s--
and call them from python or another
language so you turn your existing
processes into services if you want to
like play with them okay so now we've
covered the basics of how to use Freida
but freya also has some tools that you
can use I showed you briefly the rectal
here you can also look can just show it
again so you can do things like this and
the ref bow as well just paste it in and
if you want to call this function here
just yeah you can play around and here
you have a completion for a code
completion for the Frida's api so one
thing you might want to do now okay
we're now done with our own program
we'll can switch to some existing
software so say we have a telegram on
Mac OS we might want to know what kind
of files this program opens so we could
use Frida Trace
and we can say telegram - I open so
we'll include we'll trace all functions
that are named open in the telegram
process okay and now if I switch to
telegram and I tap or click around see
it's actually calling open and the
colors here are depending on the thread
which thread is calling the function so
you can get a sense of how this
application is designed threading and
yeah one thing you might want to do is
interact with objective-c api's but I'm
gonna show you one thing first
so this free to trace program here when
you run it like this - I opened include
a function in open yours Globes it will
generate a directory call handlers on
the file system on each library that it
matches the function inside will get a
directory and each function will get a
script so you can actually go and edit
these scripts so here I've edited the
open the Jas or I have and we can say
hello NDC open and they find now just go
here and trigger some activity inside
library loads - so you can adapt this
instrumentation as it's running and to
save time I'm going to cheat a little
bit here because I want to show you that
it can actually call functions on
Objective C api's as well not just
native api's this Frida has an
objective-c integration that is built on
top of these things that you already saw
Nate a function native callback so on to
give you a dynamically generated
language binding so it will use for
those familiar with a javascript use we
use
proxy objects to dynamically generate
things or look things up when you ask
for them so I'm afraid I can use
obviously the classes dot and the name
of the class and you get a dynamically
generated binding okay so actually let's
just write an agent here so we'll attach
to the open function okay so whenever I
open this cold will do open path equals
and then we can create a variable for
the path so mem and we can do memory
read utf-8 string to dereference the
pointer is in the first argument that's
a pointer to a string and logged out and
[Music]
so if we freed a telegram used to raffle
again and load the script here into that
process and tap around yeah see it's
working and now you could to show you
that you can integrate with objective-c
api's let's play with
let's try apples speech synthesizer
which is available as an API so we'll
just do obsequious NS speech
synthesizers and a variable and then
we're going to create an NS auto-release
pool i which is a requirement for using
this idea or using such api's we're
going to instantiate a speech
synthesizer we're going to pick your
voice and then we're going to set the
voice and we release the autorelease
pool but we have this synth here as a
variable and then in the in line hook
instead in addition to logging will also
make it speech that will have a last
speak so it doesn't do right limited a
bit let's try to fit it on there okay
let's turn up the volume and try this
slash users slash o le AV r slash
library slash group content
slash users slash user slash youth slash
user slash var slash TV slash nsurl sto
RA gev slashed officer data doc been
very useful the point is just to show
you that you can use objective-c api's
that already exists and you're running
in the context of the application so you
can combine things okay
look whenever when the application calls
a certain function you can do something
else using an existing API yeah and I
was showing this on a Mac but to prove
that freedom runs on multiple platforms
I'm going to show it on iOS too
so here I have a jailbroken phone but
you don't need jailbroken phone to use
free like you can still repackage the
app and add free data to the yeah same
with Android so fire QuickTime Player
flee I'll be able to stream the screen
or share the screen live
okay cool so there's a command called
freed up PS oh yeah I forgot to say if
you pip install free - tools you'll get
these command line tools people still
Frida you just get the API that we used
before
yeah so we can use Frida PS and we can
say just no arguments it will list the
processes running on this local machine
but you can also use well if you look at
trader LS devices you can see what kind
of device is freed and I was about so
it's local system the iPhone is
connected and then you can use free IPS
- you to just pick the first USB device
or you can use - D and the ID you're
here to pick a certain one and run this
you'll see the processes running on my
phone here and you can use - a - list
applications and I for installed so not
just the ones that are running and here
you have all the process the process is
running at the top and the apps
installed okay so I should have a
telegram app installed on my phone here
so we can use free a trace - you USB - F
just like spawn a program instead of
attaching you can either either gave it
like pin LS or you could give it the
without starting with a slash
it means it's an application so it's the
application ID so here telegram and will
include open run this launches the app
and you can see course to open
and yeah it can again you can edit the
handlers here and change it
hello NDC from iOS and if I tap around
here yeah
let's reloaded so the next question you
might have is okay now we know that
certain someone is calling open but who
is calling open so we can add some code
here called from new line tap say thread
back trace this context that gives us an
array of return addresses and then we
can do map on each and we can do debug
symbol from address and we'll can join
that that turns each one in the array
into a debug symbols if it's available
or a placeholder if not and then we join
these with new learning tap if I run
this I'll save this and go here and tap
a bit yeah so you see hello and if R is
called from the back trace okay
I'm just gonna cut jumps slightly ahead
and show you what that might look like
with a different app I know I'm gonna do
that next
so run it again
and here you see that yeah there you'll
also notice other you don't know
Objective C API statically in the back
trace and then that might give you a
hint where you should be tracing next so
you can go and go and trace those ap ice
and and learn more and more now about
the application another thing you can do
is to look at registers so if this
function has a very weird calling
convention can I look at any of the
registers so so you can do like this
context X to 0 for example to access the
X 0 register alarm 64 here go and if I
just dump the whole object with this
context you'll see all the registers
that you have access to so that means
you can deal with also weird calling
conventions or if the compiler came up
with a colleague dimensional zone
because of the noise agents still look
at registers ok so let's look at another
commercial application
so snapchat uses encrypted
communications so let's free the trace
that and I know it's using SSL readin
SSL right
those are part of the security framework
on iOS that's how it what it uses under
the hood for my encryption and
decryption yeah it's calling it and what
you might have noticed earlier is that
the generated handler actually did it
log to things for you like the argument
to open you didn't actually have to
write the code that's because there's a
really ugly hack there that tries with
man to look up the man page and then
there's a red X to find the signature
and generate some code based on that
it's not pretty but that's in frida
tools so free de três is just a I mean
nine hundred line or something Python
program it's pretty small really
primitive and it has like a poor man's
API look up there with man pages so that
doesn't work with SSL read here but if
we go and look up the docs which we
won't have time for we learned about the
signature we could also reverse engineer
did what if it wasn't already document
so I've already written this it's the
same we rewrite this beginning with the
jump or a branch and then if we can't
allocate code near enough we'll jump
through a header nearby like find an elf
or p.m. echo header trampoline through
so I have a handler here for SSL read we
get it gets the pointer to the buffer to
to read into as the second argument and
it has an outer argument in the fourth
and then
returns if it's successful we can rate
as much as its returned in the process
argument that was processed and we can
dump that with hex dump there should
also do the same for SSL right yeah so I
find out tap around a bit in the UI here
[Music]
yeah something like that
yeah so you can see it's calling a cell
rate this is the decrypted the thing
they got from the server so you could do
the same with the open SSL api's and if
the process has statically linked open
SSL that's a bit harder because you need
to find in functions but you can use do
that you can use static analysis tools
to find figure such things out okay so
another thing that's quite common is
jailbreak detection in mobile apps so
say Deutsche Bank's for app for example
it's a random example does this and
usually these jailbreak detection
schemes are using L stat indirectly to
look for a file the presence of certain
files and here you you can see it's
looking for bin bash user S Pen sshd et
Cie apps etc so and it's showing us a
jailbreak destroys the security layers
designed to protect your personal data
on your eyes devices other so this app
detected that there's a jailbreak at the
system is running on is jailbroken and
now we could use Frida to bypass their
apology jailbreak scheme
and usually then you start by looking at
the back-trace where else that is called
from then you'll find their function
that calls that's doing all the checks
and you can just replace the whole
function with a return true if if it's
like it's jailbroken and show you that
you can also instrument Android a Java
API on Android so that will look like
this you do Java perform to attach this
thread to the VM and then you can use
Java use and the class name and you get
a wrapper for that and you can do a name
of a method implementation equals on the
function or plate and then you replace
the whole implementation of that you
have a method so that's how you would do
hooking on android with java api s-- but
you could also use the Interceptor that
I already show you showed you for native
API so one cool use case is injecting
errors into applications fault injection
and so you could do like this is not
very readable
just copy
so this example iterates over connecting
connecting Oh counsel there's two
versions of connected on 32-bit or Mac
OS and then it's defining a native
function can for connect so you can call
connect itself and then it replaces the
existing implementation connect and then
in the replacement here it will look at
well the first argument is stockist next
is the address and the third is to
address length so it rates out the
address family from the the address and
then if it's ina iron it's six or inside
the port and if it's one of these ports
then it said does this or no is econ
refused I return minus one and that's so
it just returns right away however if
it's not then it's going to call through
to the original connect and that way you
can create like a software firewall
inside the processes that you want to
debug to make them think they're
firewall in certain ways and to trigger
interesting code paths and this is also
great for testing or not reverse
engineering but for testing another
thing that's interesting is there's a
there's an application that's calling
receive it's receiving data from the
network and after its received the data
it might be processing it and then
calling receive again so it might be it
depends on the architecture of the
application obviously but that's a
simple one that won't be what's
happening so you might want to know
what's happening between two successive
receive calls and I have an example here
where that's done so here we combine two
different freed API
interceptor that you saw earlier so
whenever a receive is called we use a
stalker API to start tracing this thread
and then when receive is called again
we stopped racing it and then we have an
execution trace and here I have just
visually visualized that
what this this is the agent and the the
other side that's controlling it so you
can can also build car code coverage
tools this way but what's interesting
here is that you could like correlated
with what you actually receive from the
network so you receive a one packet you
record the execution trace and you see
the different packets record it and then
you can diff to and see where they
diverge and then you know that okay here
in the code it's parsing that part of
the packet so you might want to go there
and look at that parsing logic to
understand the protocol or to find out
how you can if you're building a fasting
tool you could use to do guided the
faster to to have as much coverage as
possible and I just want to show you a
proof of concept I've did some years
back so here yeah this is a compliment
of mine we were sitting on a plane
practically like come up with a fun way
to show Freda and so we took the the
globe thing from the Google arts team
and put you right here on top we're
using the free to API and showing you
the data socket communications and also
the different file descriptors it knows
about and the cut types of sockets etc
but what's it what we also did is
whenever there's an IP address of serve
and we'll do a geo IP lookup and plot it
on the globe so you could actually get a
visualization of where the communication
is happening so this is with a Spotify
back in the days when they were
peer-to-peer I don't know if they are
still but so now if I go and play music
here if you pay attention to do the
globe here it lights up it starts making
connections all over Europe
yeah this is an example of a thumb tool
you could build or a useful tool and
then there's another one called crypto
shark it has nothing to do with crypto
but it can come up with a good name so
it's stuck
so it's a cute app written using qml
using free SQL bindings so it has a
process selector here these items come
from free data API that works on iOS too
so here you have the list of threads
that are in this running in this
application in this case it's chrome and
this - for now these threads are tagged
dynamically based on the api's they're
using so if thread is observed with
interceptors we saw earlier to call a
file i/o API then it's tagged with file
the called observed achill with an
Africa API then it's tagged with net so
this way you get a sense of what the
different threads are doing and then you
can use the code tracing API that I
showed you quickly with the all calls
between two calls earlier to actually
follow the thread and here you see the
functions that are called and how many
times and these are not exported these
are just internal functions in this
program and it's classifying them as
functions just because they were the
target of a call instruction on x86 and
then you can click around here and look
at the disassembly
of the functions that is calling and you
can also do add probe like I did here
and you see logging whenever it's called
and you can tap click on that and you
can edit the login code and it's updated
live so the idea is that you can look at
the internal another application what
kind of functions are called you can
maybe interact with the UI and see what
new functions are crawled and this could
be taken further and it could have
heuristics that will look at arguments
and try to guess and say it's so an MPEG
header a pointer to something it looks
like an MPEG header maybe
it can show you a there's a media stream
happening here in this process maybe you
want to look at here at this point
there's many things you could build to
help you reverse engineer so yeah I
think I'm out of time so any questions
it was originally free either because
iodized a static analysis tool with
Canada ambitions were like I will have
static analysis but I started
implementing dynamic analysis first and
static never happened and later I'm glad
I didn't because there's a friend of
mine a co-worker actually who's working
on radar which is a static analysis tool
competing with either open source so we
have our true freedom I oh that's a
combined a plug-in for radar where just
gives you freedom inside so I can
combine static and dynamic analysis so
yeah that's where it comes from and it's
yeah with also a pun on EDA the stock
analysis tool it has a vision female
name and Frieda
the sister so they were like complement
each other because when a static one is
dynamic yeah
yep yeah that works too
same way with the Interceptor that you
saw on thanks oh I should show you
there's a website co-chair the free data
re where people are encouraged to share
their creations and there's already a
lot there that you can learn from
Universal Android SSL pending bypass iOS
data protection look at that free to
empty route IES info it's a lot there
already but that's a great place to
learn yeah co-chair dr. freda re and the
API I was using is on the website on
Docs and then API reference JavaScript
API and I recommend the modes of
operation here it shows you they can use
for your different ways like injected as
we did before or embedded in an app or
LD preload or different mechanisms I
wouldn't worry about this because if I
mean you need to have you need to be
able to actually code on the machine so
I mean this is but this is just like gdb
it's a debugger you could use it for
nefarious things if you want to but it's
still need someone to run it on the host
if he's right yeah you if yous
interceptor it will be visible but if
you stalk her it will not because then
it will actually not touch the original
code then it will be just in time
compiling the code that it would have
been running and pretending that it's
running that code so that's for it just
to make it hard to detect that I did
that because it was I was reverse
engineering some Apple stuff and that
they had yeah some anti instrumentation
stuff but so yeah it depends but you can
there's a lot of I was seeing that
mobile apps are starting to implement
anti-freedom now some games have it so
but the good thing is that your
instrumentation code runs before the
applications code always so you can
always counter when they look for free
that you can use instrumentation to
actually make it look like free that's
not there so
that's one way but that won't work in
Mac and iOS because we have dynamic
linker there but they might connect the
localhost to a certain port which is if
you deploy on android or iOS this could
be listening there by default you can
change the port or they might try to
connect all ports and try to send the
hello and see if they get a response
yeah it's futile I think it's a waste of
time which is true because yeah not a
long story okay any final questions no
it's also used by fortune 500 companies
that but sadly not all of them are
allowed to contribute because they think
it's a hacking tool but it's not a
hacking tool it's dynamic
instrumentation framework or toolkit so
but yeah so and no legal trouble so far
yeah I mean yeah but it's there's
nothing illegal about it in my opinion
so okay thank you
[Applause]